hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to time or inferno now this
is a there's a pleasant opening screen
to a game that I have played before or
at least I played the prior incarnations
of this game they came and they took
everything I'm just a girl they took
everything
mommy daddy they tried to take my dolls
I couldn't let them I couldn't let them
take my dolls they made me angry I
killed them
only my dolls will remember my anger
okay whoo oh hey oh I thought that was
the game for a second there I was like
it was a plan oh okay so this I don't
recall if any of the other time or games
cost money but this one actually did I
got it off yo there's a link in the
description if you wanna check it out
but it's the only one that costs money
so my expectations are raised whoa hello
nice effects uh-huh
at least they improved the door sounds
but if it's anything like the other time
or games I expect a lot of very very
high quality jumps carriage oh look what
am I looking at why am I looking what am
I looking for oh they shouldn't have
come here you shouldn't have either oh
hi I don't like mannequins did I ever
mention that to anybody around here you
are just uh full of beans
oof oof okay skip pardon me her oh hi
hello okay [ __ ] off with that okay hi
what are you doing can I help you yes
oh is
on my grave great gurgi ah just good old
time or fun times surrounded by jump
scares oh boy I actually don't know how
long this game is either because if it
is a if it is longer than the other ones
I might maybe break it up into a couple
parts but I'm not a hundred percent sure
about that just yet I uh by the time you
see this I have to go out into town for
a friend's wedding just for a few days
like only a few days but I got to
prepare for it so I have no idea yeah
those are just boring details that you
guys don't need to worry about this is
stuff I'll get you your videos no matter
what I mean obviously you're here thank
you for being here and joining me and
watching I was ball oh oh he's almost
adorable oh look at you is you just a
bag of dicks defend yourself don't hurt
her why shouldn't I oh oh I didn't know
that [ __ ] I've done bad I done bad
I'm sorry your dad thank you that's what
I get alright fine I get it I don't what
No are you [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] off with
that I can't go back to the beginning
what there's no save system off [ __ ]
that okay so apparently there's no safe
system so I'm going to be following
instructions to a tee because I don't
want to have to restart every time I die
so I'm not gonna hurt her it's gonna be
okay I'm a happy fun mark EMU walking
through the woods with an ax no one's
gonna get murdered here unless I have to
defend myself and if I die again under
very pissed okay anyway talking about
stuff and things walking through the
woods I'm getting a hundred percent very
heavy cry of fear vibes if any of you
remember I've often I've had an idea
that I wanted to play through cry fear
again on a live stream at some point
just because I remember when I played it
after I beat the game you could restart
the game on like a New Game+ on a
different difficulty level but there was
like a whole different campaign that was
a part of cry fear that was just locked
a wolf right what do you do I will
defend myself against you try me try me
try me
Friday
know what you are whoa-ohh
that was all about but I defended myself
and my axe is a little bloodier now I
hope that's good thing
wait was a crime figure no it was a
different game Oh what was it it was
gray oh man I almost completely forgot
about gray but that was true there was a
lot of crime for your stuff that I
missed out on
- but kruh gray have the like different
campaign that's right i man all these
old-school games everything I did that
you know the the hot pepper thing and I
was reminiscing about old videos that I
did I went back and I looked up some old
videos that I've done and it was just
really interesting nostalgia trip to see
why'd you cut out there huh oh I got
closed in huh oh I remember your time or
tricks yeah but there's a lot of old
okay as I was gonna be huh
you're gonna remind me a slender man
while I'm talking about old history now
that was a big chapter of my existence
on YouTube slender man the whole amnesia
Slender Man phase the raging debate
about which one was scarier oh man I
remember the slenderman's shadow maps
ooh ooh hey I will defend myself whoa I
don't know if I should be looking at
that guy well is he looking at me no
he's not looking at me Oh No
okay hello okay bye-bye
Oh fine fine give what what huh - I
thought so I thought this game isn't
giving me any room to think or say
things about the past but what I was
saying about the Slenderman shadow maps
is I remember eagerly awaiting a new
like everyone in the whole world was
like waiting for a new game to come out
so that they could play it and make
videos about it uh and he made the curse
of Blackwater if you remember that one -
why do I gotta traverse the ocean of
blackness like the ocean of blackness
it's a pirate's dark water oh here we go
anybody oh I almost feel safe oh it
feels oh good another one I was hoping
to do this again la la la la la la la oh
is that another oh okay whoo whoo whoo
whoo whoo all right here we go whoa what
are you okay just a weird ashen car do
my doth my eyes deceive me is that color
over there no those are teeth never mind
I thought those were like Windows on
built those are teeth oh oh hey hey
little guy Oh God oh man the developer
this game just has a field day with
making bizarre things okay
hi body her friend how you doing
let's see don't play with it okay fine
then I won't
oh [ __ ] you whoa [ __ ] off
are you gonna fight with it I would
never
Oh ladies Yogi's good I wanna go through
this again something's gonna pop out it
better [ __ ] you I can't see I'm
imagining if I touch any of they're
gonna kill me I didn't play with it just
cuz I was looking at it doesn't mean I
what [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay all right it's gonna carry on like
that didn't happen
I've also just been carrying on like I'm
not surrounded by giant teeth I'm trying
to find a moment to relax but I don't
think that's gonna give it to me in this
game ah whoa what's this version of oh
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
no no no good [ __ ] hard you go what what
is that ha ha good hope I'm hitting it
yeah gonna weird spider you oh god I'm
dead I'm dead aren't I oh whoa god damn
it that look bad
whoa what the [ __ ] I thought that guy
was gonna [ __ ] me up why is it looking
at you why is what looking at me Oh God
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] you what are you doing what
are you doing I don't know why it's
looking at me huh oh is this is gonna be
my buddy now well I'm gonna call you
Oliver the I Oliver the oculus well
Oliver come on with me we're Oliver and
company
I should probably swing my axe at you
frankly you're just too darn adorable
what am I going into the darkness help
me see Oliver cast some light on this
scenario Hey who why what are you doing
Oliver just stay behind me Oliver whoa
okay
I'll arrange did this thing have well no
thanks Oliver don't worry you always got
my back you're always looking at my
crack they're not be talking smack
oh man Oliver cut me some slack oh let's
get this road back on track okay
going into the castle I suppose I guess
I'm out of the teeth woods which is nice
oh yeah closed closed corridors that's
what I remember
Oliver you still there good I wouldn't
want you to run away from anything at
all
let's go Oliver we have an adventure to
take care of Oliver ah oh no I lost
dollar ah okay Oh Oliver
oh no no Hey Oh No
what are you yeah what are you Oh Who am
I asking I have no idea
I lost Oliver though okay whoa what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] off dude what are you doing oh
yeah God what's wrong with you ah he's
so weird don't do that get away from me
I hope I'm hitting you I don't know if I
am there we go that's the stuff that's
the juiciness am i hitting you ready
there we go good you're dead somehow I
don't know how but it happened a
beatdown
I will say I as much as I like there's a
special place in my heart for the time
or games one thing that we can say about
him is that they were never built very
well you know I mean I'm just I'm being
brutally honest but I'm being honest
nonetheless no one can look at this and
be like that's a top quality game right
there that is um so I'm not very nice
you always kind of go into it being like
I know it's gonna be cheaply made and
you know not gonna look pretty but hey
it's gonna be it's gonna be an adventure
hey how's go
okay never bye then okay hi huh
it's still following you Oliver oh [ __ ]
were you lying to me huh you lying lying
and what's following me I don't know oh
[ __ ]
treinen just trying to trick me it sound
tricky trying to trick me yeah trying to
make me paranoid and looking behind me
Oh Oliver hi Oliver
whoa hi how are you doing welcome back
Oliver glad you didn't die I'm happy
that you're gonna be recording my entire
adventure here okay come along Ollie
hello hi how's it going how are you
doing did you catch the game the sports
event boy I was a thing that happened
between the teams
Oliver up Ollie's gone well into the
darkness whoo what do we have here hmm
okay hello hi how's it going
defend your room what whoa I know [ __ ] I
goddamn it this bad this bad this bad
what if I die oh [ __ ]
that'll sound good
I really hope a [ __ ] oh god damn it
oh [ __ ] off oh [ __ ] off oh [ __ ] out whoa
I don't think I was supposed to go
through the map there okay how did I do
it did I do it okay that was fun glad
that happened huh boy what next
oh hi hi friend how you doing okay oh no
I was supposed to get whoo oh well
alrighty then hello how are you doing
lovely day for it okay it's quiet
oh [ __ ] you too quiet
uh-huh I want to uh under all these
cloth-covered objects hello how you
doing
I'm I spoke hi what the [ __ ] are you
I sure am glad that I'm the mass
murderer in this equation whoo hey
you're just gonna watch huh that's what
you like don't you hmm
[ __ ] you ollie do I gotta kill you all
he get out of my way Ollie come over
here you gonna come on Ollie jeez I
can't believe I'm accommodating you
ollie oh yeah there we go get out my way
yeah the back use even grosser than the
front of you that's saying something
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hey hey well
time or you got an upgrade you got one
hell of an upgrade okay bye I don't care
why are you back I don't know if that's
Timmy Timmy time or oh ah two of you do
I get a chop through I will I'll do it
all right fine it yeah
that's Pleasant yeah I'm glad that's
part of the game experience or boy hello
hey how you doing
you're good I can already tell by just
looking at you you got something planned
for me and I know much care for it what
do you got you huh what are you gonna do
you're gonna pop out at me you're gonna
pull another monster out of your
butthole to come chasing me down the
hallways hell are you gonna do god oh
[ __ ] off with you I knew it I knew it
fine that's how it's gonna be I guess it
wasn't all that bad all things
considered just a tiny little bitty be
to do all hi what happens if I chop you
mmm oh nothing okay all right I'll move
on then bye bye friends have a good one
love you Oh Oh what is that oh no
someone hang hung Hank
someone's hung someone's really hung I
don't think I can crawl so here boy this
is fun to look through hey little girl
are you okay by then you gotta go I
understand I'm too ugly to hang around
horribly again sweet kid all right okay
I'll go back the way I came yeah that's
cool no it's fine with you [ __ ] out with
you forgot with you [ __ ] off with you
[ __ ] off with you [ __ ] off with you [ __ ]
off with you there you go
[ __ ] off no one can stand up to me I'm
too horrendously strong no one can
withstand my punches oh hey hello again
whoa well that don't look good if I know
a thing or two about scary-looking girls
in white dresses at the end of the
hallway shaking sporadically with lights
flashing from seemingly nowhere it's
that it's bad so let's charge right for
it why don't we hello
oh no she's shy hmm oh hi oh I can run
again
oh I can leave oh okay then hello you're
slightly red defend yourself hurt her
oh god
hi whoa geez oh geez oh geez oh geez oh
geez oh geez
[ __ ] [ __ ] ah geez hurt her I will
cooperate for you I'm the monster here
you can't stop me yeah yeah
Jesse I really am the monster hey well
where is she
presenter where Zekey
wow man you coward what are you doing
hurt her hurt her I got no qualms about
this [ __ ] maybe I shouldn't have done
that
oh she's trying to run away from me huh
oh really we're gonna play these games
huh
well I'm persistent is all help oh
you're gone oh okay
ah [ __ ] I'm a monster
I've been caged I'll get you okay fine
then okay run run run
okay fine then Hey oh it's you
uh listen it was a lovely night the
other night but look I uh to be honest
it's don't like the fact that everyone
around me keeps dying when I'm dating
you this is a little bit problematic I
gotta admit um [ __ ] off you won't hurt
me anymore I wasn't trying to oh that's
it again
okay that is time or inferno very much
reminiscent of all the other time or
games I will readily admit but fun
nonetheless I mean discern whatever
story you want out of it I think it's
just kind of like a haunted house
jump scary type deal not bad combat was
kind of wonky but then again the whole
games kind of wonky but it was cool
nonetheless so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you
in the next video where my legs so itchy
all of a sudden what is it doing to me